ich nenne es big demokratie unseren
europäischen weg nach vorn
höchste zeit denn der große raubbau
unserer zeit findet nicht nur an der
natur statt sondern auch an unseren
daten den daten die wir freiwillig und
jeder zeit überall im netz hinterlassen
die maschine cheffe 220 milliarden
dollar in einem einzigen quartal ein
echter globaler goldrausch vier der fünf
reichsten männer der welt machten ihr
vermögen mit der plünderung eine
ressource die eigentlich allen gehört
unseren daten doch es gibt eine frau die
sich mit dem vielleicht größten
diebstahl der menschheitsgeschichte
nicht abfinden will francesca bremerin
professorin un beraterin
das ist ein ganz und gar unfaires
geschäft und die konzentration von
marktmacht in der digitalen ökonomie ist
beispiellos
denken wir nur daran dass die großen
tech firmen über einen marktwert von
etwa 9 billionen dollar verfügen und
dass dieser wert während der pandemie
noch einmal drastisch gestiegen ist
firmen wie amazon apple microsoft google
und ihre chinesischen äquivalente
tencent alibaba und beide haben über
eineinhalb millionen dollar gewinn
gemacht während der rest der wirtschaft
in die rezession gerutscht ist
noch vor zehn jahren läuteten die fünf
wertvollsten unternehmen des planeten
fossile bodenschätze aus heute plündern
sie digitale ressourcen
dabei funktioniert die sprichwörtliche
datenkrake nur weil wir unsere daten
kampflos und kostenlos den konzernen
überlassen und dann für deren dienste
bezahlen die es ohne unsere daten gar
nicht gebe doch eine andere welt ist
möglich davon sind die vorreiter einer
neuen digitalen gemeinwohl bewegung wie
francesca überzeugt ihr kerngedanke der
souveräne bürger muss die hoheit über
seine daten behalten und digitale
technologien müssen zuerst den menschen
dienen nicht dem profit weniger großer
konzerne
wir müssen verstehen dass daten teil der
infrastruktur sind und dass wir sie als
öffentliche güter als gemeinschaftliche
güter betrachten sollten sie
die luft die wir atmen wie unsere
straßen wie unser energiebedarf wir
sollten daten nutzen wie eine
öffentliche infrastruktur die werte für
alle schafft
als digital beauftragter von barcelona
hat francesca brier die stadt
umgewandelt in eine soziale smart city
ihre idee die daten der bürger müssen
dem gemeinwohl dienen nicht dem profit
seitdem gibt es in barcelona mehr und
bessere gesundheitsversorgung
effizientere müllabfuhr weniger verkehr
ein modell für die demokratie in
digitalen zeitalter
[Musik]
wir können die demokratie voranbringen
indem wir digitale plattformen für die
bürgerbeteiligung nutzen denn es gebe
den bürgern mehr macht auf die politik
ihre städte einzuwirken wir können den
klimawandel bekämpfen weil wir
emissionen und luftverschmutzung besser
messen können wir können unsere städte
sauberer werden lassen indem wir uns in
richtung einer vernetzten
elektromobilität bewegen und so weiter
die verwaltung einer modernen stadt
braucht daten um bessere entscheidungen
treffen zu können und um effizienter und
effektiver zu funktionieren
francesca bria entwickelte eine digitale
plattform auf der die bürger vorschläge
zum regieren machen und darüber
abstimmen konnten sie entschieden über
verkehrsberuhigte zone über die anlage
von grünflächen und darüber welche daten
an die politik und an unternehmen
weitergereicht werden durften und welche
nicht
wir haben etwa 400.000 bürger
miteinbezogen auf einer plattform namens
des idm barcelona
dort konnten die bürger etwa 70 prozent
der politischen tagesordnung des
stadtparlaments direkt vorgeben
unser digital demokratisches modell ist
ein hybrid das auch offline elemente
beinhaltet
damit für die bürger in ihrer
nachbarschaft und ihrer gemeinde
ansprechen können
lokale lösungen für ein globales problem
die welt befindet sich in einem neuen
kalten krieg auf der einen seite big
data der überwachungs kapitalismus der
amerikanischen tech giganten auf der
anderen seite biggs date die
totalüberwachung china und europa
europa muss einen eigenen weg gehen
weder in richtung eines digitalen
autoritarismus noch in richtung des
überwachungs kapitalismus von big packs
ich nenne diesen weg demokratie
unseren europäischen weg hin zu einer
daten demokratie wir müssen die macht
und die werte die wir mit daten
erschaffen um verteilen und die bürger
in den mittelpunkt unseres modells
stellen und technologie dafür nutzen die
drängendsten probleme unserer zeit zu
lösen
ist big demokratie der einzige weg aus
der ohnmacht gegenüber den großen
raubbau
klar ist so lange wir am sozialen leben
teilnehmen können wir gar nicht anders
als daten zu produzieren als teil der
verwertungslogik des netzes zu sein
ist entwicklung die lösung einfach
verzichten sich aus allem raushalten das
netz ist überall und damit auch der
ständige zwang zur vernetzung eine
rückkehr zu analogen und vernetzten
zeiten wird es nicht geben worauf es
ankommt ist sich strategisch immer
wieder den netzen zu entziehen freiraum
schaffen inmitten der reizüberflutung
ganz nach dem motto von herman melvilles
bartleby
ich möchte lieber nicht
digitalisierung kennen wir und mit
analogie sierung meine ich
genau die die tatsache dass das analoge
nicht einfach so existiert wie es diese
traumbilder uns nahe legen sondern dass
das analoge hergestellt werden muss urs
stäheli ist professor für soziologie und
forscht über den wunsch sich der
allgegenwärtigen vernetzung zu entziehen
denn längst schafft das allgegenwärtige
netz eine stetige unruhe die us stähli
netzwerk fieber nennt er fragt wie
können wir lernen dass and netzen
innerhalb der netzwerke zu denken wie
organisiert man in netzwerken die
möglichkeit von entnetzung also die
möglichkeit nicht teil eines bestimmten
netzwerkes zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
zu sein wie organisiert man das lockern
das kappen das zerschneiden von
verbindungen ohne dass dies einen
vollständigen ausstieg aus den
netzwerken gleichkommt und die paradoxie
ist also dass das um dies zu
organisieren
die techniken die mittel von netzwerken
genutzt oder benutzt werden müssen ein
ernüchternder aber realistischer gedanke
nur das netz bietet uns die möglichkeit
und dem netz wieder zu entziehen ein
ratgeber zum digital die talks zum
beispiel oder des connection apps die
uns für eine bestimmte zeit vom netz
nehmen und den kopf wieder frei werden
lassen um in ruhe darüber nachzudenken
welches netz wir eigentlich wollen diese
offenen ins unbekannte gehenden linien
können auch zu politischen linien werden
indem nämlich die frage auf welche art
und weise wie stark wir vernetzt sein
möchten und in welchen
zonen wir nicht vernetzt sein möchten
dass das eigentlich eine politische
frage sein muss
eine frage die wir uns dringend stellen
müssen denn die algorithmen der
netzwerke führen emotionen ängste und
hunderttausendfach im fall facebook
gewaltbereiten trump anhängern gruppen
die zum sturm aufs kapital fließen in
deutschland nutzen
verschwörungstheoretiker netze vitaler
telegramm und nicht zuletzt facebook wie
soll man sich verständigen wenn man in
unterschiedlichen netzwerken liegt
sobald man sich überhaupt nicht mehr
aber die ähnliche informationskanäle
verständigt schwindet auch die
möglichkeit und die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass leute sich noch dass dinge
ausgehandelt werden dass man sich im
diskurs begibt und versucht über dinge
zu streiten und die beste lösung zu
finden und dafür sind glaube ich
geteilte informationen es wird ja
häufiger mal gesagt jeder hat sein recht
auf eine eigene meinung aber eben nicht
auf eigene fakten und gerade dafür sind
natürlich die medien extrem wichtig
neutrale oder zumindest ausgehobene und
gute berichterstattung zu liefern judith
simon ist professorin für ethik in der
informationstechnologie in hamburg sie
forscht über die folgen des
verschwindens der alten massenmedien im
digitalen und darüber was das für unsere
demokratie bedeutet ihre vision
vielleicht müssen wir unser gesamtes
mediensystem neu erfinden und ein
gegenmodell zur macht der konzerne
entwickeln eine große rolle dabei können
institutionen spielen die nicht
gewinnorientiert sind universitäten die
europäische union der öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk womöglich sie
könnten die basis bilden für ein
netzwerk das von inhalten getrieben ist
nicht von profil
die öffentlich-rechtlichen medien die es
dann sein sollten haben ja eine
substanzielle finanzierung jetzt auch
einsetzen sollten um ihre inhalte
hochqualitativ auszurichten aber auch an
den nutzer interessen orientiert und die
frei verfügbar zu machen viel stärker
mit offenen lizenzen zu arbeiten sachen
frei verfügbar zu machen und da auch
ihrer rolle gerecht zu werden dass sie
das in bestimmten informationsauftrag
haben an die bevölkerung und dem eben
besser als es bis jetzt auch noch getan
haben vielleicht noch besser gerecht zu
werden der informierte bürger als
mündiger souverän seiner daten francesca
prete zufolge ist es höchste zeit dass
europa sich behauptet und eine andere
digitale welt aufbaut längst geht es
nicht mehr um einzelne fragen wie
wettbewerbs kontrolle und besteuerung
sondern um europas souveränität
wir riskieren zu einer digitalen kolonie
zu werden eingezwängt zwischen den
vereinigten staaten und china
europa muss seinen eigenen weg und seine
eigene geopolitische strategie für die
zukunft finden wenn das soziale modell
europas überleben soll
wenn wir unsere demokratie nicht
voranbringen und mit alternativen
aufwarten mit auf teilhabe gründenden
demokratischen bewegungen wenn wir
unsere institutionen nicht stärken ist
dann riskieren wir erneut den aufstieg
von rechtspopulismus und nationalismus
zu erleben wie wir ihn in den letzten
jahren gesehen haben
noch sind francesca briand sie den
zukunftsvisionen aber ein
selbstbestimmtes
gemeinwohlorientiertes netz scheint
möglich
wir müssen es nur wollen